WA MOSKVA IS
ND ASSMENT AR FLAGSHIP OF
SAN A
RESULT OF ON BOARD FIRE.
A RUSSIAAIR STRIKEN KYIV S, TWOI
TODAY WAKELY RETALIATION FOR
TH
RE EXPRESSING
HE SINKICAE BOMBIN
>> Translator: THEARSHIP A CAUS
IT IR FLAG.
THERE IS NOT TABOUT.
THER.
>> MUCH LL DOHERTYND CLARK, A SR
FELLOW AUCLA.
BOTH.
JILL, IN BEGIN WITH U.
WHEN YOU HR STAT REALLY SENEMY
CAFOR OOHE THAT, SD WE
THE OFFICIAL STORY TO ANN
THAT RUSSIA WILL G THIS WAS
N KNOW.N THE WAR?
BUT RIGHT W, I WOULD SAY
LOT AN PROPAGANDA IS CONTRADTO
SLIGHTLY DERANGED I'SES.ED IT A.
IN SHOW AND IN ANOTHERIS
UKING THAT AT,HE
SH.
IT WAS PLANNED I
NOW, OF , IFS IANSOT THE PARTY
LINE.
AND THENR SSIANS TO ADMI NS COUT
HATO
ME UNITED
, IT ALL
TO THE UNITED STATES.
>> IT TO GET TO THAT.
PE POTENTIAL ON HERE.
BEREL CLARK, THE
MOSKVA, THN AIR DEFENSE
ITSELF.HE BLACK SEA FLEET APPARL
I WO H AT IS FOR JW VANCED THE .
K COULD
HANDLEEY DAC
N ONA TIME ITREMELVULNERABLE.
NORMLYS OPERATE IN A FMA
E MULTIPLEHIPSWORKING TOGETHER.
POSSIBLY T RUSANWERE AR
GU.
THT
NING
SHIP.ATEVER UANS'GET AND BUILST
OUP DOWN
HEAR IT FROM  FROM THE .
T JUSTT T
RT
RE RIGHT?TLKINT
HAWO,  FEAR THATE PROP,  S BEGIO
RUSSIAN TV.
OF C.THOUGTHWS
EY AS TRIAOO.E Y
SOMETHING AND TH
CONSTANTLY POLLING AND LOOKIEOT.
AND THEY CANEASE A LITTLE
TRIAL BALLOOAB.
AND THEN IULGROW. BREPEATED
SO IHI
NC IN WHA.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE IT COULD GO
BUEVELOP THAT WAY.
MAN ON SHOW, I THINK AS
ID WE
FIIN
WHAT IS IT CALLED?
O REMIND.
SPECIAL MILITARY OPERATION
BUT THE G S WAR.BU RUSSIAN DEFI
WAR, THEN Y G
STEP FORWARD
AND IF IT IS WAR ANALUNGAFT.
THE TALKINABCH
MOREPERSONNEL.
BATTLEFIELD,
THE LOE FLAGMEANUS?E THERE HAS A
SAUL.R FLAGSHIP EVE ANIN
ABOVE WATER OFF THE COASOF THAB
FOR NO
>> I WOULDN'INK IT IS
TOLLTHE TABLE,INE CONCUS
AMPHIBIOUS ASSAULTS.EAT AREA
IT IS NOA  BROAD
BEE TO SHORE ON.S TOUGH TARGETG.
THEY KNOW IT AND THE
RIEADY TO